[Music]
so as joe biden continues his push
of dangerous open borders amnesty
and yeah catch and release america last
immigration
agenda well white house press secretary
well
circle back jenn saki is in complete
denial about the damage that their
policies
are causing record numbers this month
alone
that's right over over a hundred
thousand
take a look i'll ask it again
will he acknowledge that there's a
crisis well first
the president and this administration's
focus is on digging out of
the dismantled and inhumane immigration
approach of the last
administration you say that's not a
crisis
well i think what uh ambassador jacobson
and secretary
uh majorcas were conveying and what i've
conveyed is
it doesn't matter what you call it it is
an enormous challenge
we don't feel the need to you know play
games with what it's called
at this point is this a crisis at the
border look i don't think we need to sit
here and put new
labels on what we have already conveyed
is challenging
why has this administration been so
reluctant to call it a crisis with a
huge
uptick in the number of migrants being
detained including thousands of children
if that doesn't qualify as a crisis what
does well because we think that it's
most important to explain the
substantive policy of what's happening
hey chen it was joe and barack
they built the cages and put the kids in
the cages
now they're putting kids in cargo
container
you know shipping container things with
bars on the tiny window you won't let us
see it
now this is all happening because of
biden's policies
he has caused what is now yes a crisis
as yes thousands and thousands of
migrants illegal immigrants flocking to
the border
undocumented with covid by the way and
they are being released
into american communities facilities
used to house migrants
are operating beyond capacity in the
middle of a pandemic
seems to be no end in sight no social
distancing and i don't see a whole lot
of mask wearing either
that's not a crisis heroes reaction is
the host of
lara logan no agenda on foxnation.com
and texas lieutenant governor dan
patrick
let's start with the news lara hundred
thousand
thirty thousand kids now we got cargo
shipping containers that they're putting
kids in they won't let any television
cameras in
we're told oh but there are butterflies
on the walls i'd like to see the
butterflies
how many kids are in the cargo shipping
containers why are they hiding it from
all of us
they're not just hiding that part of it
sean they're hiding it
all along the way and i was just talking
to a few people in law enforcement and
agents
down at the border and this is their
take they said why would the
administration call it
a crisis when it was planned because
they know and i was following this in
real time
with a number of different sources they
were told from the moment that biden
came into office
that they were going to shift from a
border security mission to a migrant
care mission
they were told that special units would
be shut down and some of them have like
the bicycle units
they were told that agents would be
taken off the line and taken off
security patrols
to process and take care of um
immigrants and that is exactly what has
happened
and they've just been told that in the
midst of these numbers
they are now the biden administration
from monday is going to start
processing all of the people who were
returned
to mexico under the previous
administration's remain
in mexico program so according to uh
reported figures
that was about 65 000 people that were
returned by the trump administration to
wait
for their asylum claims to be heard but
to wait inside mexico not within the
borders of the u.s so as of monday
if this administration was concerned
about the numbers and considered this to
be a crisis
they would not be opening up another
avenue
for more people to be coming in and to
have their claims now
processed they're now going to wait for
their claims here and what i was told is
that they're going to do them in groups
of about 25
at a time around 100 a day although the
agents have been told to expect those
numbers to go up
and that the mexican government is going
to be testing them for covert
so one question um that has to be asked
of the biden administration
is who is going to pay for that testing
of all of these people
and um and also sean i would just say
that
that number that you cited for
unaccompanied minors
what many people have missed is that
that number is on a par
in five months of this fiscal year with
the whole of last fiscal year
and we haven't even gotten to the point
if you follow the migration patterns on
the border
in the summer months they go way up so
come april
you're going to see more and more and
more people coming across
and even without the summer migration
patents we're on track
for a hundred thousand unaccompanied
minors
just this year alone wow well lieutenant
governor
um we have the unaccompanied minors
issue we can't see the cargo shipping
containers i would like to see it
remember it was biden and obama that
built the cages and put the kids in the
cages
not donald trump donald trump stopped
that program
the covid what positivity rate
overall in texas was as high as what
near seven percent
and one town near brownsville and that
sector
it was as high as 25 that's true
yeah well we don't know the exact number
sean but higher than our general
population and the fact that they're
putting them on buses and sending them
anywhere in the country that we do not
know
flies in the face of anything the biden
administration has to say to american
citizens
about what we do to protect ourselves
from kovid they're just letting them
into the country there's no social
distance
distancing there's no care about uh them
being
in our cities uh across this country
they just don't care about that let me
tell you
some numbers sean in 2004 the the
chamber of commerce
said there were 10 million illegal
immigrants in this country we
averaged apprehending about 400 000 on
the border every year but about
three or four times that many get in
that we don't catch so that's over a
million a year sean so since 2004 we're
up close to 30 million
this year alone sean just in the last
month
we have gone from apprehending 11 000 a
week
in texas to 22 000 a week in texas so
we're on par to apprehend
this year close to a million
immigrants coming across this country
many children a lot of single adults
though
sean so if we catch one out of every
four that means that's maybe three to
four million
alone this year sean coming into texas
we're facing a this is an intentional
design disaster
this is intentional by the obama
administration
right unbelievable all right thank you
both